BOB: Thanks for
coming, everybody.
Virginia Heffernan has
written for "The New York
Times," for "Slate,"
for "Wired,"
for "Harper's," "Yahoo News."
We won't hold that
against her, though.
I actually read the whole
thing over the weekend,
and that's saying something,
because I don't always
read these books.
But it's a really good read and
I encourage you all to buy it.
We have a lot of people
talk about, oh, the internet
is changing everything,
and you're probably
as tired of it as I am.
But this isn't really like that.
This has made me think about
things like why pictures are
taken over the internet--
because even though I was here
the whole time, it didn't
kind of surprise me--
and also why
telephone calls were
really good in the old days,
and now they kind of suck.
But what Virginia's going to
talk about today especially
is YouTube, in fact
reading from her chapter.
So please welcome
Virginia Heffernan.
[APPLAUSE]
VIRGINIA HEFFERNAN:
Thank you very much, Bob.
This is like really is
like being at Angkor Wat.
I've never been to
Angkor Wat, but I have it
in my head, in the same
place in my heart and brain,
as the Googleplex.
So I live up to it.
Live up to it.
I usually just talk, but
because you're Google,
I thought it would be
interesting to talk
a little bit about
my fascination
with YouTube before
the Google acquisition.
"So cast your minds back
to January 25th, 2006,
when a mysterious
image showed up
on YouTube, the video
sharing site that
was then only three months old.
A sinewy figure in a
swimming pool blue t-shirt,
his eyes obscured by
a beige baseball cap,
was playing guitar.
Sun poured through
a window behind him.
He played in a yellow haze.
The video was called
simply "Guitar."
A handmade title card gave the
performer's name as Funtwo.
The piece Funtwo played
with mounting dexterity
was an exceedingly
difficult rock arrangement
of "Pachelbel's
Canon," the composition
known from the turn of the
century for solemn chord
progressions and
overexposure at weddings.
But this arrangement,
attributed on another slide
to someone called Jerry C.,
was anything but plodding.
It required high-level mastery
of a singularly demanding
maneuver called sweep picking.
Over and over the
guitarist's left hand
articulated strings with
barely perceptible movements,
sounding and muting notes
almost simultaneously
and playing complete
arpeggios with a single stroke
of his right hand.
The video was
thrilling to watch.
Almost instantly I was hooked.
I hadn't yet seen
selfies of any kind,
hand-held or selfie
stick-enabled,
nor had I seen video
on Skype or Facetime.
So I wasn't accustomed
to this intensely focused
exhibitionism, the pleasingly
distorted self-portraits
and moving pixels, often of
family and intimate friends,
that now flood our screens.
Funtwo's own selfie video
was curious, masturbatory,
David Hockney colors
plus chiaroscuro.
The effect was not wholesome.
The video lacked the creamy
resolution, crystalline audio,
and voluptuous
effects associated
with professionalism, and with
even the average MTV entry.
Amateur.
Homemade.
Flawed.
Not so much mesmerizing
as provocative.
The critic Harold Bloom
wrote that "to behold
is a tragic posture.
To observe is an ethical one."
Funtwo required near
clinical observation.
You didn't behold this video
as you might a Hollywood movie.
Enraptured by the spectacle,
you inclined toward it
and you studied it
like a scientist.
You peered as at scrambled
porn on a high and forbidden
channel.
As soon as I leaned forward, I
had reached for Tolkien's ring,
or tasted some
life-altering drug,
or crossed a magical line,
and there was no going back.
Just as Nabokov forces us to
take Humbert Humbert's language
into our very mouths in the
opening of his great novel
of child rape, Lolita,
the tip of the tongue
taking a trip of three
steps down the palate
to tap at three on the teeth.
This video seemed to implicate
anyone who watched it.
I played guitar
again, then again.
A small miracle was quietly
happening in those first months
on the site.
The bonafide pornography
that was widely
expected to drive out
all other video genres,
as a predator plant strangles
diverse flora and unbalances
ecosystems, never showed up.
Without actual porn, the
subtle voyeurism of guitar
stood a chance of becoming
a hit with viewers.
And hit it was.
By the end of its
first week on YouTube,
the video had already been
viewed one million times.
By 2016 its various versions
had drawn more than 10 million
views, and for years
it was regularly
listed among the
most seen snippets
of online video in the
history of the World Wide Web.
We are now used to numbers
like-- 10 million views you
probably didn't even look up.
But I was reviewing
television at "The New York
Times" at the time, and
no one could get a view.
The people that had
made "30 Something"
put up a new show on
NBC, and you know,
they got 15 million
viewers the first night,
and this is on the networks.
So I was reviewing television,
and I saw this video,
and it was like--
Marshall Hereskovitz, who
made "30 Something,"
said, where is everybody?
Where are these viewers
I've been looking for?
When I went to YouTube,
I realized, they're here.
I know where they are.
Working as a critic
and a columnist
for "The New York
Times," I'd acquired
some unusual new habits
since YouTube launched.
Guitar only threw the
problem into relief.
As network television
contracted,
the media business folded
dozens of magazines,
and YouTube was
acquired by Google
for $1.65 billion
dollars-- again,
sounds like a small number now--
with other one billion-plus
tech acquisitions and giant
IPOs in the offing-- I found
myself mystified by how
much time I spent away
from the tattered armchair
tokens of my youth--
books, magazines, newspapers,
the broadcast networks,
and the ever-present
murmur of NPR.
While there was still
achievement and pleasure
in the old media, it was clear,
too, that the dogs had barked.
The great caravan that brings
knowledge and ideas that
shore up human
enterprises had moved on.
I renewed my subscriptions
to "Vogue" and "The New York
Review of Books" until
I didn't anymore.
Back issues piled up
on my coffee table
and then became part of
recycling, landfills,
and compost.
They weren't culture,
they were carbon,
part of the problem gumming
up the environmental works.
The same thing
happened to the novels
that I ordered in
hard copy from Amazon.
The spell that had
been cast over me
by inked letters on
white pulp was broken,
or more accurately, a
new spell had been cast
on a separate part of my brain.
The deeper I ventured into the
civilization I found online,
the more I realized I'd need
more new models of courage
and imagination to contend with
the trippy, slanted, infinite
dreamland of the
rapidly evolving web.
Funtwo became my hero.
The velocity, intricacy, and
exactness of his performance
modeled the rhythms and mental
requirements of the web itself.
Funtwo's guitar video speaks
to me now, a decade later,
just as a chalice of
certain dimensions
tells us something
about the people who
inhabited a lost world.
From a chalice we know how
big were the hands that
were meant to hold it, how much
liquid people liked and could
consume, what kind of liquid,
cold or hot, basic or acidic,
they considered potable,
what type of surface
their cups might sit on.
The dozens of hours that I
spent feeding my obsession
with guitar were not
wasted, or not entirely,
or so I told myself.
That video was, in
fact, as Funtwo--
who was born Jeong-Hyun Lim
--told me when I finally
met him, it was intended
to be instructional,
an early contribution to the
now encyclopedic how to category
on YouTube, which I
would later consult
to learn umbilical care
for my infant daughter
as well as how to shield
an iPad from scratches
and how to make progress
in a Wii game called
LEGO City Undercover.
That's not cheating.
That was learning
how to make progress.
For me, the video contained
a powerful suggestion
of the kind of person
I'd have to become
if I was to keep a clear head
in the new medium that had come
to dominate my mental life.
And I was not alone.
The internet was pervading
the lives of all of us
who were growing into
this newly transmogrified
social and aesthetic space, from
my neighbors and colleagues,
friends and children, to
musicians in Taiwan and Seoul
and all the 1.4 billion
active users of Facebook.
In the Funtwo days, well
before the efflorescence
of elegant services like Spotify
for music, Reddit for ideas--
every time I say that
someone's like, elegant?
Ideas?
But anyway, Reddit for ideas,
Pinterest for collages,
and Instagram for photographs,
before Steve Jobs's death,
and even before the iPhone, the
socialization mobilification
of everything, then
the move to wearables,
so-called internet of things, 3D
printing and virtual reality--
right then the web asserted
itself as its own culture,
right at the dawn of Web 2.0,
when newly expansive broadband
permitted the
dissemination of video
and the rise of
social networking,
the internet became something
more than a reformulation
of the offline world.
With cries variously
of agony and triumph,
we had to stop pretending that
email was a handy alternative
to telephones or post.
Fluid and never ending
electronic exchanges
made the word communication
seem inadequate.
Similarly, newspapers on
the web could no longer
be considered mere
adaptations of newsprint.
1992 flashback.
This is an actual trauma
that I still can't
believe I included in the book.
A traumatic moment
in early adulthood
came just as I was having
doubts about my first choice
of career, academia.
I had started a PhD program
in English in 1991 just
after graduating from
college, but though I
was supposed to be
refining my skills
at rigorous academic
prose, the grubbier work
of Greil Marcus-- I understand
he just spoke here--
whose book "Lipstick
Traces" took seriously
pop culture and a pop idiom
captured my attention.
I also would try to
copy Camilla Paglia's
outlandish
observations about art,
though they were considered
suspect in university settings.
One day my highly
traditionalist father--
he's a college professor--
nailed me for this.
He has a very
mid-Atlantic accent,
like right squarely between
New York and London.
Virginia, your prose
can be a touch glib,
or rather meretricious.
What's meretricious, Dad?
Oh, Virginia, come on,
meretrix, from your Latin,
like a prostitute.
Oh.
Did you get nothing
out of Latin camp?
My father called
me a prostitute.
This is not an easy
dialogue to recall,
but the eccentricities
of the early '90s
are a useful
reference point when
taking the measure of
the internet's influence.
These were the days
before the web.
The Mount Vesuvius
of digitization
was faintly rambling,
but most of us
were determined to
block out the noise.
Sure, there was email,
but texting and tweeting
had not yet made glibness-- my
kind of glibness-- compulsory.
The meretrix, by other
names, had not yet
become an Instagram paragon.
Mandarin and emoji had not
yet left Latin in the dust
as second languages of choice.
These were exciting
times, filled
with these transitional
technologies,
desktop published
zines and other forms
that presaged blogs.
But cultural loyalists were
still hoping to hold on.
Today holding on is impossible.
The tectonic shift has happened.
"The New York Times"
daily newspaper
and the company's news apps
are starkly disparate entities.
Uber is something other than
a municipal taxi service.
Airbnb is not another
kind of hotel.
E-commerce at eBay,
Amazon, Etsy is not
analogous to catalog shopping.
It has its own rules,
conventions, implications,
pace, and pricing.
Between analog and
digital are more than
differences in degree.
Between them is a
difference in kind.
Like all new
technologies, the internet
appears to represent the
world more faithfully
than technologies
that preceded it.
And the internet is an
extraordinarily seductive
representation of the world.
We've never seen a
work of art like it.
That is the book's
central contention,
that the internet is a
massive and collaborative work
of realist art.
And moreover, it's so
beguiling a realist showpiece,
and so readily confused with
reality, that books about it
call themselves books about
business, politics, or science,
the reigning bywords
for reality itself.
That is a mistake.
Digital forms are
best illuminated
by cultural
criticism, which uses
the tools of art
and literary theory
to make sense of the
internet's glorious illusion,
that the internet is life.
Because of course the
internet is not life.
It's a highly artificial regime
with tight rules and rituals
that organize its text,
music, and images.
That's why the internet
becomes more deeply meaningful
and moved when read
as an aesthetic object
than lived or reported on as
firsthand human experience.
The human experience is art.
That human experience is art,
where art is considered closer
to a game than to a deception.
Our proxies in this
game are our avatars,
the sum total of all
the profile pictures,
message board communiques,
Snapchat videos,
and all other artifacts
of text, image, and sound
that we add to the internet and
attach to our various handles.
The game itself in
artwork is without doubt
what video gamers call a
massively multiplayer online
role-playing game.
It's funny, because I'm having
to cut things out so that I
don't over explain to
all of you-- I mean,
you know what a massively
multiplayer online role-playing
game is, but sometimes
people don't.
So I'll save you my very labored
explanation of what they are.
Digital life in its current
extremely visual, social,
portable, and global incarnation
rewards certain values,
and they're not the ones
many of us grew up with.
Engagement, emotional
expression, liberalism,
tolerance, self-knowledge,
irony-- these values
of the '70s lost a
great deal of urgency
at the turn of the millennium.
So I felt that I
was trying to learn
a certain new set of
values, a new aesthetic,
and a new politics-- a new way
of being, a new modus vivendi.
And while I was
trying to learn, I
practiced the
finger work required
by my laptop, my BlackBerry,
and eventually my iPhone.
And what writers workers,
teachers, parents, students,
artists, and
companies all appeared
to be trying to learn,
too, these new skills
and interpretive methods, many
of which didn't have names yet.
Just as one example,
when the Funtwo video
and some other videos from
YouTube and other early video
sites came over my desk, I
was writing about television
at the "Times," and as I said,
I thought, oh, maybe this
is something interesting
that I could write about.
My more senior
colleague in TV got
to write about "The Sopranos"
premiere and "Six Feet Under"
finale.
And so I was sort of writing a
lot about reality television.
And so I was looking for
a way to make my name,
write something exciting
about something new.
So I saw this online
video and I thought,
you know what would be great?
"The Times" could
host all this--
I called it internet television.
I still have a folder on my
desk for internet television,
because I was a
television critic,
so I wanted to persuade
everyone that I could now write
about internet television.
It would be like cable.
So I had this idea
that "The Times"
would host a video a day,
all the video that would ever
appear on the internet.
We would host it on
our site, and then
I would write a capsule
review of each one,
and it would just
be this daily thing,
because I thought
that we would probably
see about one video a
day on the internet.
You guys know the
numbers that you do.
So after dusting off hundreds
and then thousands of videos
on YouTube-- this is another
thing I think about YouTube--
you know, art forms like color
field painting or punk music
usually start in one place,
and they have names attached
and they grow outward.
YouTube, it was like
discovering a lost civilization.
I mean, I should talk
again to Hurley and Chen
about this-- I know the
first one that was up there,
but I don't know
at what point they
started to get
close to the numbers
that YouTube has
now for uploading.
I mean, it seemed as
though there was never
a time that there weren't
at least a million videos
on that site, that you weren't
looking at three one day.
And so it was like dusting off
these hundreds and thousands
of videos and seeing
the civilization
that they composed.
Online video isn't a new
art form, like punk music.
Instead, the art of the
internet and its rules
came into view all at
once and fully formed.
All over the world amateurs
had apparently spent the years
since the birth of camcorders in
1982 and digital video in 1986
shooting, producing,
collecting, and transferring
home movies, video art, pet
and baby videos, surveillance
videos, including some that
showed police, interpersonal,
and corporate misdeeds, music
performances, ads, trailers,
sermons, lectures,
comedy sketches, theater
scenes, pornography, magic
tricks, athletic stunts,
pranks, medical anomalies,
virtual tours, news broadcasts.
All of these were just waiting
around needing an audience.
Now by 2016, more than
100 hours of video
are uploaded every
minute to YouTube,
hours that come with a dizzying
range of styles, themes,
and provenances.
Many of them had
clearly been produced
well before the possibility
of online broadcasting ever
existed, the 1950 coronation of
Queen Elizabeth, for example.
The first videos
mounted to YouTube
included a scene of
civil disobedience
shot in a bus in Singapore, a
monologue by a Best Buy clerk,
and fully 14 short movies of
mammals playing with shoelaces.
Every single one of them
zinged around the web
and collectively attracted
far more passionate responses
than the multimillion
dollar slates of new network
television that I
regularly reviewed.
The internet favors, speed,
accuracy, wit, prolificacy--
someone just corrected my
pronunciation-- prolificacy,
and versatility.
But it also favors integrity,
mindfulness, and wise action.
For however alien in
appearance, the internet
is a cultural object
visually on a continuum
with the cultural
artifacts that preceded it.
It's not a break with history.
Neither is it progress.
It's just what
happened to be next.
The internet's responsiveness
to critical tools,
the kind used by English
majors, historians, bloggers,
readers of every
stripe, including
rogues like commenters,
trolls, and kneejerk tweeters,
has been elucidated in the
stuff that I've studied,
Baroque audiovisual projects by
composers and sound designers.
The hallmarks of
internet culture
come through in experiments like
Netflix and Amazon Originals,
arguments and reports
serialized on Twitter,
podcasts like NPR's "Serial,"
and the new media franchises
of reality TV heroines.
Anyone can witness this from
the front row, the emergence
of a new hierarchy of values at
Wikipedia, Facebook, Twitter,
G-- here, Instagram, Spotify,
Snapchat, Skype, and so on.
But companies rise and fall
on the strength and value
to advertisers of what we at
Yahoo News-- where I covered
digital politics during
the 2012 election--
we used to optimistically
mystically their assets--
visual, auditory, or textual.
At least they
weren't liabilities
while I was making them.
These assets are nearly
always ironic, cartoonish,
or dramatic extensions
of established and even
ancient art forms, aphoristic
poetry suitable for Twitter,
painterly images for Instagram,
polemics, essays, and reports
for Facebook.
The web represents a
grand emotional, sensory,
and intellectual
adventure for anyone
willing to explore it actively.
Alarmist tracks that warn about
how the web endangers culture
or coarsens civilization
miss the point
that the same was said,
in turn, about theater,
lyric poetry, the novel,
film, and television.
Having written about television
for such a long time,
I got really used to
writing about something
that was treated as an
art at "The New York
Times" on the culture pages--
so I sat next to someone that
wrote about opera, music,
museum shows, books--
but treated as a
public health hazard
in the rest of the newspaper.
So this is not uncommon,
and in some ways,
I like that what we do, what
we immerse ourselves in, is
considered, in some ways,
like a neurotixin or disease,
that we're addicted to it.
Things that make
you feel truant,
like you're doing something
that you shouldn't be doing,
that tends to be-- as Bob
and I were discussing--
those vulgar art forms
tend to be thriving.
You know that an
art form, I think,
is in trouble when there are
suddenly MFA programs in it.
So it'll be time to sell
Instagram, short sell
Instagram, when there's
suddenly an MFA program
on the art of the selfie.
The internet is the
great masterpiece
of human civilization.
As an artifact it challenges
the pyramid, the aqueduct,
the highway, the novel, the
newspaper, the nation state,
the Magna Carta, Easter
Island, Stonehenge.
Anyone want to argue?
Agriculture, the feature film,
the automobile, the telephone,
the Chanel suit, the airplane,
the pencil, the book,
the printing press, the
radio, the realist painting,
the abstract painting, the birth
control pill, the elevator,
and cooked meat.
As an idea, it
rivals monotheism.
Just as in Nietzsche's
scheme, man
created science,
which in turn killed
god, analog culture--
that's books, clocks, film,
industrial machines,
the compasses and timers
of scientific method.
Those things created
digital culture,
and now digital culture
has superseded them.
It was quick, that
supersession, and now it's over.
But where are we?
Magic is a word Apple
vigorously embraced,
and it's a term of
art from engineers.
I don't want to
summarize because I
know I'm in company that is
probably above my head on this,
but as I understand it, a
program is magic to the extent
that it makes what would be
very complicated processes
seem easy.
And the word loss
in the title comes
from the problem of
lossy compression,
so that the MP3 form of
representing a musical signal
tends to compress that signal,
to thin it out somehow.
And it loses something.
What that thing is, is what I
want to take the measure of.
So in digitization,
digitization is lossy.
This civilization is lossy.
Its effort to represent
and reproduce what
went before it loses something.
And that's what the loss part
of the book attempts to size up.
35 years ago, when I
first discovered it,
the internet wasn't
easy to find.
It wasn't a user friendly retail
franchise as the web is now.
It was a nervous back office
full of furtive clerics.
You stumbled in.
While computer hardware
and software of the 1970s
were the work of
sophisticated engineers
who pressed computers into
the service of everything
from music to word processing,
architecture and film making,
the slow and awkward
networks in those days
had limited application.
These were the so-called Eve
networks, inspired largely
by ARPANET, the landmark-- I was
going to tell you what that is,
but I think you know.
Logically, the internet
in its early days
was kind of a diversion for
Cold War intelligence types
and academics.
But it was possible
to stumble into it,
and I know because
at nine years old,
I was one of the
stumbling years.
Excalibur was an early
social networking technology
developed at Dartmouth College.
It was the heyday of
Dungeons and Dragons.
It was 1979, and in that day,
the vaguely King Arthur theme
appealed to both hackers
and tweens like me.
Now Excalibur's real purpose
was to facilitate communication
among several academic and
scientific institutions
that shared Dartmouth
mainframe computer.
It was one of those
big, heaving rhinos
that, in a cage of bulletproof
plexiglass, sighed and rattled.
Every day a few
hundred people dialed
into that mainframe for an alien
signal like [SCREECHING SOUND].
I loved that sound.
I mean, when I first heard
that sound, I was like,
that's all the information
in the world just coming
in to my life.
We would fit our receivers
into these acoustic couplers
like people into kayaks.
As a townie pre-teen, I
hacked in with the help
of some shaggy, kind
Dartmouth students
who called themselves sysprogs.
In those days, Dartmouth sysprog
sounded tantalizing to me,
the way lead singer sounded
to some of my classmates.
John Kemeny, then the
president of Dartmouth,
had co-written the computer
language BASIC in 1964,
inspiring a generation of
student programmers who got
called Kemeny's kids.
They built this extraordinary
Dartmouth timesharing system.
Most of them are out here now.
The sysprogs of the
1970s and early '80s
also tended this mainframe as
it shook and rattled in its cage
on the edge of Dartmouth's
colonial campus.
So with some friends, I found
my way to their computer center.
Our trick was to
tell our parents
that there was no way we
would be able to work for NASA
unless we hung out
with these guys all day
and played Dungeons and Dragons.
It was a pretty good little
scam we had going on.
It's 10 years after
the moon landing,
so anything that you
could tell your parents
to help you get to the moon,
they were happy to oblige.
With some friends, I found
my way to the computer center
to talk about BASIC.
Kemeny had taught rudimentary
BASIC at the local Yankee
school children, presumably
to win the freedom
to pursue his non-Yankee plan
for ARPANET on the Connecticut.
To mollify our
parents, we told them
we were going to work for NASA.
But the little girls of 10 and
11 who stormed Excalibur never
made tech history.
That worked for us at the time.
All the better to enter the
shadowy world of Excalibur,
and especially an
addictive live chat feature
called Conference XYZ,
without being noticed.
Conference XYZ amplified
Excalibur's fantasy element.
Each convocation had levels
and a self-anointed master
who could banish
chatters he disliked.
So if you signed on
early in the morning,
you'd have to get a code.
It went off at night,
like TV, but you would try
to get up early and sign early.
And you needed the code of
the day to be able to sign on.
So we'd have to call each
other and tell each other that.
And the sysprogs would set that.
So if you got on first and you
were the master-- oh my gosh,
you've been there.
Did I see you on Excalibur?
I was Athena.
I was nine.
So you would sign
on, and then you
could just banish
anyone you didn't
like if they were talking.
I mean, I would be fun to
do this on Twitter someday,
because people would
talk in public space
and just reply all.
And if they swore, and
you would always say back
to that-- there was a
macro for keep it clean,
folks, for some reason,
keep it clean, folks.
But also, these guys at the
Merchant Marines Academy
would write in all caps.
And for some reason that meant
that they were ideologues.
Even if they were
saying normal things,
just writing in all caps was
a way to get yourself killed.
But then sometimes one
of the Merchant Marines,
one of the caps people,
would be the master.
He would have gotten
the code, and you'd
be like, oh, it's going to be
such a bad day, because he's
going to hush all
the people we like.
You know, I went on because
I was nine, 10, 11, 12.
I just couldn't get heard
at the dinner table,
and I had some very interesting
ideas about Reaganomics
that I wanted to share with
anyone who would listen.
And you know, I don't think
it's unlike how lots of us
come to the internet now.
You feel too young or too
old or too fat or too black
or whatever for a social life.
And so if you're uncomfortable
in physical space-- you know,
I wasn't athletic, and
I was a good writer.
So I could be a superstar.
I could be Athena.
And it was extraordinary
how fast this thing grew.
There was an article in "The
Atlantic" maybe 10 years ago.
But it said that
every time they find
bones of primitive
people, primitive man,
nearby those bones are the bones
of a domesticated wolf, a dog,
that there's never been humans
without dogs really nearby.
And one of the
contentions of the book
is, there's never been
engineering without culture
right next to it.
So there's never been a time
that people were creating
the internet that they weren't
also posing as Apollo, Athena,
or whatever, to chat with
each other about end runs,
but ultimately about
anything, about what they
were having for lunch.
So I bypassed the part where
I could have learned to code.
And the four other
people that were
interested in John
Kemeny's talk-- all boys--
didn't moon for the sysprogs.
They went off and
actually learned something
and probably work for NASA now.
But yeah, so this is
a book-length effort
to justify my decision to be
Athena, and not learn Fortran
or whatever.
In any case, the culture
that we were creating-- well,
by the time I turned
13, I was confident
the way I would later
be confident that I'd
seen every single video online.
I was confident that I knew
every single person online.
I just was like, Apollo,
Bumblebee, me, it was a list.
I had 100 of us in my head.
My parents couldn't have guessed
that I was meeting anyone.
They just saw me sitting hour
after hour at a computer.
The computer was Zenith
Z-19, a dumb terminal.
It was like a
ChromeBook in the sense
that without the mainframe,
there was nothing in it.
Just had to dial into it.
And I just would
stare at that thing.
You guys can remember
it from "War Games."
It's like these green
phosphor letters in the front,
and then this just deep yonder,
just dark space behind it.
And I just would peer into
that space and just wonder what
was out there.
People were saying things in the
foreground about Reaganomics,
about Dungeons and Dragons,
about Led Zeppelin-- huge topic
of conversation on
Conference XYZ-- runes.
And I would just
try to speculate,
how are they getting in here?
What in that squeal crash
sound is bringing all this
into my life?
And there was a huge
amount of projection.
I see it in my kids when they
look at a Minecraft screen.
It's like practically
illegible to me.
It just seems so abstract.
And yet when I hear
them talk to each other,
they say-- there are not
enough of these videos
on YouTube, by the way, of kids
playing Minecraft and talking
about it.
But you know, they're looking
at something-- just looks
like this kind of beigey,
greenie, ochre blur--
and saying to each
other, like, we're
going to need a tribunal
because you killed my sheep.
That's actually a real thing.
And I mean, they might as
well be looking at a brick,
to me, for as much
sense as it makes.
And I was having this
incredibly emotional experience
in essentially looking
at this dark screen
and really coming of age.
I got off because I
finally met someone.
His screen name was
John G, so he had
a kind of normal screen name.
And I told him that
I was 14, and he
was 18, Dartmouth student.
And he asked me to go
to a bonfire with him
and play with light
sticks or whatever.
So I went on my first
date with someone
that I had met on there.
And I was really excited,
and I told my real friends
the next day that I had been
out with this 18-year-old guy
and I was really excited.
And it's kind of
like, maybe, when
you meet someone on
Bumble now, or Tinder
or whatever, that you
don't want the question,
how did you meet him?
You just want to delay
that for a little bit.
But anyway, Hallie Davis asked
me, how did you meet him?
And I was like, just
this game that I play.
And she was like, is
that on the computer?
And I said yes, and
she said, desperado.
And suddenly, I was like, I will
never look at a computer again.
And I didn't.
I closed it down.
The story of early
computer networks
has most often been told as a
technology and business story.
But like the internet
today, Conference XYZ
was not an engineering
experiment as much
as an immersive experience.
What mesmerized me
and its other users
were its cadences and
its vocabulary, its vibe.
On some level, while we
were seeking connection
and community, we were also
helping to build a culture,
and today I see that
culture writ large online.
All the same little
cultural flourishes, like
are you going to write in
all lower case, or all caps,
or mixed cases, or use little
hyphens instead of em dashes,
or make Reply All errors.
I just remember it was
like this rite of passage
that you were going to mess up
with RA, Reply All sometime,
instead of replying right to the
person, and get hazed for it,
and learn.
Conference XYZ pretty
much folded in 1986.
For years I half-repressed
thoughts of Excalibur.
It would come back
to me in fragments,
the odd jargon we evolved, the
hot feeling of being watched,
the invective, the
jokes, the speed.
The highly collaborative
project had
been a spontaneous
creation of a scene
and a modus vivendi,
an entire culture.
Had we really done all that,
and was it really gone?
It was not gone.
What I thought was the end of a
short detour from regular life
was actually the beginning of
the biggest cultural phenomenon
of our lifetime.
If it's fair to say
anything changed everything,
it's fair to say so
about the internet.
At stake in this cultural
transformation are the way
we live, think, love, talk,
and fight across the globe.
The internet is
entrenched, and it's time
to understand it not as
a curiosity or an entry
in the annals of
technology or business,
but an integral part of our
humanity, the latest and most
powerful extension NS expression
of the project of being human.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks so much for coming.
VIRGINIA HEFFERNAN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm particularly
interested in why people
will take the time
to post on YouTube
and build up their
audiences, especially
as it relates to
sharing expertise,
especially if that expertise
isn't socially credentialized.
So to them, the expertise
is like how to use Snapchat
or how to clear the
cache on your device.
And so I'm curious
what you think
are the elements of a successful
atmosphere that encourages
that type of behavior.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I couldn't tell that-- I thought
that Funtwo, Jeong-Hyun Lim's
video, when I first saw the
guitar video-- do people
know what I'm talking
about, that video?
Wow.
All right.
Well, in that place
where all the conference
rooms are named
after viral videos,
forget about Coke and Mentos.
They were talking about
guitar, lower case G.
I thought that
was a music video.
I read it as a music
video when I first saw it.
And when I finally
tracked him down
through Naver, this Korean
social networking site,
I actually saw him in person.
He's a missionary, and
he came to New York
and played that
piece in Astor Place,
with his cap pulled in
hopes of being recognized.
And a couple people were
like, that's that kid.
And he played with the
Red Hot Chili Peppers.
He had kind of a career.
So he explained to me that
it was a how to video.
And it was a how to video,
and this is astounding.
So downstairs in
his living room,
he would practice
violin and piano,
which he was expected to do.
But upstairs in
his room, he wanted
to do this kind of shred
guitar that was in a Baroque--
but that's Pachelbel's
Canon piece.
So it was like
Baroque chamber music
that he had been doing
downstairs, but then upstairs
with headphones
into this webcam.
So he became-- there's a
Japanese term, hikikomori.
It's [? charisma hiki. ?]
It's a famous shut-in.
So a person that
doesn't leave their room
but becomes famous
on the internet.
And so he was sort of that.
He had all these
followers and people
that were interested in
his version of this thing.
But he's extremely
shy, and a lot
of virtuoso guitarists
who hide behind makeup
or hair or a bucket--
there's bucket head.
And he pulls his
cap over his face
almost entirely while he plays.
So you can see his fingers.
So when I talked to him I
said, why did you do that?
And he said, I wanted to show
people my way of playing,
and I also wanted
feedback on it.
The reason that chamber music
existed in the first place--
chambers, so that
you don't just hear
the music recorded,
because the hope is you'll
be able to do it, too.
So you want to come up close
and see the instruments
and see how people
are doing, how they're
playing the harpsichord so
you might be able to reproduce
the finger work.
And you can't do
that at a distance
if you're seeing it on stage
at the Beacon or whatever.
So in a weird way,
he brought back--
something that complicated,
that he brought back
this way of getting
really close to it
and looking at it
with this video.
But he also pulled his cap down
because he only wanted people
to hear the music.
And he also believes
he's very ugly
and just didn't want to be seen.
I was so used to reading it
through an American lens,
I was sure this
was a bid for fame,
like he was a kid that
made a video in hopes
of getting a record deal.
And while we were in New York,
a couple of record labels
wanted to meet with
him, and he just
didn't want to meet with
them, because for him,
the whole thing is
feedback, like what
do you think I did wrong?
He would skim the
comments, and they
were like, this guy's
better than Hendrix.
This is the greatest
thing I've ever seen.
I think it's a hoax.
The sound's not synced.
You know how the first ones
are usually like, holy shit,
and then later they're
like, this is a fake.
It's always like that, like
you could just be like,
[NON-SPEECH].
So he ignored those and
then just paid attention to,
he has a weird way
of moving his pinky,
or the vibrato's
wrong or whatever,
and just try to improve
his performance.
But then also, he wanted to
show people what he had done
and see if they would do it
back, because he was also--
I know it's going a little
far in this one thing--
but since it was
such an early entry
and it wasn't labeled
as a how to video,
I feel like-- I
just used YouTube
to find out how to fold this
tent, really hard pop up tent.
And you know, none
of them are pros.
It's not short.
It's not clear when they do it.
So I have to watch
a ton of them.
But so they're doing
something, as you say,
other than just showing
their expertise.
And I think that's
what he was doing, too,
being vulnerable
about his mistakes,
but also wanting to show,
look at the direction
I took this in for this
kind of back and forth.
The last thing I'll
say is, in the US,
this bothered him a lot.
It was kind of like the
heyday of Green Day,
or at least he thought that
everyone here was listening
to Green Day, and in Europe.
And he was like, we're
so good at guitar.
Why do you all listen
so much to people
who are so bad at the guitar?
And to find people that
wanted to be really, really
good at this particular
kind of music,
he needed to communicate with
midwestern Americans and people
from northern England,
because they were apparently
the only people interested
in playing this really
complicated guitar music.
And they didn't have a
tablature language in common.
So when they first saw
online video-- and that's
why they were such early
adaptors-- they were like,
oh, finally, this is a way to
talk about music without taps.
And so all that went into it.
So when I saw these tent
people, some of them
are trying to create a brand
a little, bit you know?
And they're like, one of
them is like Sexy Camper
or Urban Camper or something,
where she's just like,
I hate getting dirty,
but I go camping.
And you have to wade
through her persona
to be like, how do I
get this tent down?
And then there's
another person that,
like Funtwo, doesn't like his
head in the picture, you know?
But he's pretty good.
But you know, some people
trying to do selfies,
it's really hard to see it.
But I piece them together.
And also people have such mixed
motives for being on YouTube.
I think some of
that is that tension
that I love in that video.
I mean, I'm assigning
you to watch
the video because it's so good.
But it's the level of
shyness from here up.
It's like
[? charisma hiki. ?] It's
like shyness, shut-in,
don't see me, I'm ugly,
and then this incredible
virtuosity down here.
You know, anyone before YouTube
or before online video who's
going to pick up a guitar
and play for a room of people
has to have chutzpah
and arrogance.
And I think the first
discovery that he just
could be really damn
good at this piece
and play for people was
sort of a revelation.
And I think Sexy Camper has
done that too, a little bit.
She's like, I wear makeup
while I go camping,
and I want some points for that.
Yeah, I watch a lot of
haul videos, you know,
videos of people who've
just been shopping,
and then they just--you
guys know haul videos?
Oh, yeah.
Then they just take out
clothes and they just like,
I got this top, I
got these socks.
They're going to be great.
I got this.
Just go on forever.
But I mean the thing is,
why are we even speculating?
There's Twitch.
People just like to watch
weird things, you know?
And I mean, I had hung
around the networks,
and they were guessing,
what do people want?
Like is the "Friends"
model stale?
If we make two of
the friends obese,
will that be interesting?
And then online,
they're like, how
about guitar videos and haul.
And racking up the views.
So I don't know, I hope
that sort of addresses
your question.
BOB: By the way,
I'm going to sneak
in one before this gentleman.
A lot of people,
including some Googlers,
are really embarrassed
about YouTube commenters.
I think you have a different
point of view, don't you?
VIRGINIA HEFFERNAN: I do.
I mean, YouTube
commenters are where
the rubber hits the road
for the id of the internet.
And you either love
them or you hate them.
I love them.
I mean, I just--
polyglot, I mean, just
with enormous
allowances for the fact
that so many people are in
their second and third language,
and are not practiced
in reasoned dialogue
and exchange of views.
I do a little bit in here with
comments on a Beyonce video,
and they're incredibly powerful.
I mean, if you like the
arc of a YouTube comment
section, the holy shit,
this is fraud thing,
or just, this is a
Betty Page video,
you need to look at this.
People just, deep dives into it.
I don't understand.
Everyone hates YouTube
comment sections,
and yet people write YouTube
comments all the time.
So I'm not buying this, because
there are so many YouTube
comments.
Oh my gosh, if Google decides
to shut down comments like they
keep doing.
I mean, this is not a
nanny state world here.
We can be subjected
to-- I mean, what,
there's like white nationalism,
and there's people swearing.
But there's a lot
more than that, too.
There were muggers in
New York City in the '70s
and it was still a
great time to be there.
AUDIENCE: No problem.
Thanks for coming
to give the talk.
So I think for a lot
of us who, I would say,
before Google was our first
experience of the internet.
And you were talking
about Excalibur
and having this kind of-- it
was kind of like a private club,
almost, and you get
in, and you're like,
oh, I'm the only person who has
internet access in my block.
And you're like, the number
of people I'm talking to I
can count on two hands,
that sort of thing.
And now in 2016, people
coming on the internet
for the first time,
it's much more public,
and it's much more
about-- people
use the phrase sharing
culture, that sort of thing.
How much do you think that's
changed the, definitely
like the performativeness
of being on the internet,
but just our culture on
the internet in general?
VIRGINIA HEFFERNAN: Yeah.
I think that the culture
works in this very--
to put this very schematically,
a dialectical way.
So there's pushback on that.
So Facebook has us register
name, rank, and serial number.
I'm not Athena anymore.
My face is connected
to my children.
I'm beholden to and
responsible to a whole bunch
of images and words
that keep me in bounds.
I mean, Facebook
is for me, at 46,
a wonderful retirement
community that
is blessedly free of any
of you lively young people.
And we get to talk
about, like, we're
Democrats and
Republicans, and we
have reasonable conversations.
And then Twitter, where I
also spend a lot of time,
is obviously a different idiom.
There's more bots.
You can make up names.
And that has more of the
rough and ready world
that I remember, or that I
like in YouTube comments.
But the carving out
of those small spaces
so that you can have
that experience again
is what I see as the pushback
against the Facebook monolith.
So secret Facebook
groups have been amazing.
I just saw one, this
gay one for Hillary
that's called Hillary is
Madonna, where they just
spend a lot of time talking
about how hot she is
and how great all
her outfits are.
And I'm on a bunch for
Hillary and a bunch
for people in my demographics,
some of them my neighbors.
And it's just like 15 of us, and
it might as well be Excalibur.
I mean, we're just on
there all the time.
It's in depth.
We know each other.
It's invite only.
And I was just talking
to this aspiring rapper.
And I was like, I
mean, you probably
have something for music.
And he was like, actually,
I have one for couponers.
He belongs to this
board for couponers
which has 50,000
members, and they
share information on couponing.
And he gets so many
deals that I was like, I
need to look into couponing.
But I get a lot of this
understanding of the internet,
and in this book,
from urban theory,
so the tension between a
Robert Moses highway builder
builds big tower blocks,
and then Jane Jacobs,
who admired the '50s way
that you cobbled together
a little neighborhood with
tenements and little bodegas
and places to sell things, and
ways that things kind of worked
themselves out.
And there are still
so many hybrid spaces
like that on the internet.
I met this woman in
Montana not long ago
who said she doesn't
use the internet.
She doesn't like social
networking, Facebook,
it's too public.
But she's had one
use for it, which
is that she's been a member
of a total Web 1.0 message
board for people who
suffer from fibromyalgia.
And she's been using it
for 18 years or something,
and she said, I'm finally
meeting my best friend.
She's coming from New
York, my best friend,
and I have never met her.
I've been talking to her for
18 years about our sickness,
and she's coming to meet me.
And I said I thought
it sounds like you
use the internet in
a really good way.
You know, that's
like a power player.
And I've been surprised at how
many nooks and crannies are
thriving in a kind of pushback.
It's hard to codify it.
It's hard to make money on it.
You know, it's like
the haul videos.
Those are the times
when like the culture
delights you, because you just
have no idea where it's going.
Prison Talk is a huge board
for incarcerated people
and the people who love them.
You don't need to report on
the nationwide penal colony.
Just hang out on that board.
It's amazing how the texture
of prison life-- I mean,
just the fragment of the board
devoted to poetry by prisoners
in various prisons is
itself extraordinary,
and something no one
would have predicted.
It's an, I think,
15-year-old board
started by a felon
who's out now,
and he advocates for internet
access and prison reform.
And it was amazing to
get that glimpse of that.
So I just think that the
culture maintains itself
in a really beautiful way.
So once we have
one fear-- I just
was hearing that it's
possible that people
don't want connected homes.
And I just gave a
talk on Bloomberg TV
about connected cars.
And Millennials
say that they know
cars are all going
to be connected
and they expect them
to be connected.
But just because we expect
it as this horrible matrix
inevitability doesn't
mean it will happen.
The culture will
surprise us again,
and people will push
back on it, and they'll
create maker
culture and foodism,
undigitizable experiences
that have risen
in tandem with the web,
people going to dark internet
or taking tech sabbaths
or whatever, but even
more strenuously, or
reviving vinyl or live music,
or even seeing each other live.
I mean, one of the first
promises at IBM was like,
oh, this is so great, we never
have to go into an office
again.
We'll be teleconferencing
all the time.
That's the last thing
anyone wants to do now.
You want to look at
someone's crazy capillaries
and-- did you hear
about this guy?
He's not at Facebook.
It sort of sounds
urban myth-y, but he
had an addiction to Facebook.
That's what he
thought, and he really
wanted to jump off his phone.
So he started doing
an LSD breakfast.
Is this well-known?
OK.
Oh yeah, you know.
So a tiny microdose of some
hallucinogen in the morning.
And he discovered-- he
lost interest in his phone
because the faces of people on
the bus became so compelling.
And you know, faces are
really a lot more interesting
than our screens.
We look at that same
little few square inches,
and then just look at a person.
Steve Jobs said that
he wanted screens
to be oleophobic, like no
oil could stick to them.
And Johnny Ive hates humans.
He just thinks we're
disgusting, basically,
and doesn't want us to get
our sticky gross human selves
on screens.
But our sticky
gross human selves
are really beautiful
and fascinating.
You don't need the LSD.
AUDIENCE: You were reading
this out of your book,
and so now I can
actually quote it back.
But you say digital forms
are best illuminated
by cultural criticism, and
it shows the internet's
glorious illusion that
the internet is life,
because, of course, the
internet is not life.
It's an artificial regime.
And I'm wondering, do
you really mean that?
I mean, it sounds like even
from the rest of your questions,
you're like, art
is a part of life.
And everything that's
happening online
is real just as much as
everything that's happening
face to face, just
different, right?
And so I'm wondering if you
could say a little bit more
about what your thoughts are on,
this is real or this is fake,
it's made up, it's online,
it's not real life.
VIRGINIA HEFFERNAN: This
may sound like a copout.
I love that question.
This may sound like a copout.
Marshall McLuhan
said at one point
that electronic circuitry
is orientalizing the west
and collapsing
binary distinctions.
And certainly the one
between, is this deception
or is it true, would
be one of those
that I feel like the internet
has pushed on really hard.
So I say illusion, but the
kind of illusion that I mean
is the illusion of a game
where we have these proxies.
Like when I was playing
Dungeons and Dragons,
there used to be this fear,
this dread fear among adults
that we might start
actually thinking
we were high priestesses
and clerics, and snap,
and go into the Dungeons
and Dragons world.
And there was even a novel
about it, and you know,
it was right around the corner.
But I didn't think I was
a high priestess any more
than when you're
playing Monopoly,
you think you are a shoe.
I really wanted to
win at Monopoly.
I really put a lot of investment
in getting Broadway and getting
Park Place getting building
houses on them, and you know,
I'm the shoe.
I've got this much money.
But I knew that I didn't
have that much money,
and it wasn't hard for me
to draw that distinction.
The same way that when you
willingly suspend disbelief
to read a novel, you both know
that the things are happening,
and they're not happening.
It's no fun if you
don't invest in them.
It's no fun if you don't
care about the characters.
But to over invest in the
illusion-- and by the way,
there have always been fears
that people would turn Don
Quixote and believe the
things in novels, too,
and start to be like the readers
of Dickens-- who were like,
little Joe died, we need to
petition to bring him back
to life--were in misery, where
you believe the characters are
real.
But that's not all of us.
Most of us can live
in that understanding
that this is an illusion.
It's not real life.
And it's pleasurable
to commit ourselves
to it-- sometimes
painful-- but sometimes I
think my Twitter handle
takes sniper fire for me,
keeps my soul safer.
It's better, because all
those-- this picture of me?
This one made on a computer,
with very few elements taken
from my flesh and blood person?
She does a lot of work
for me out in the world.
Just like, you go deal
with these people.
I'm going to sit home.
Anyway, thank you so much.
This was really fun.